DR. MARC SIEGEL JOINS US TO
ASSESS THE GROWING THREAT.
BUT, FIRST, A STORY THAT HAS
NOT RECEIVED NEARLY ENOUGH
ATTENTION.
IN CITIES ACROSS THE
COUNTRY, PROSECUTORS AND
LAWMAKERS ARE WORKING
FRANTICALLY TO MAKE LIFE
WORSE FOR NORMAL PEOPLE AND
EASIER FOR THUGS AND ARMED
ROBBERS.
WE TOLD YOU ABOUT NEW YORK’S
NEW BAIL LAW, THE ONE THAT
LET’S CRIMINALS BACK ONTO
THE STREETS IMMEDIATELY
AFTER BEING CAUGHT.
NOT SURPRISINGLY, CRIME HAS
SURGED.
THIS HAS SHOCKED NOBODY
EXCEPT MAYBE CHRIS CUOMO’S
BROTHER WHO RUNS THE STATE
AND WHO IS RESPONSIBLE FOR
IT.
NOW THERE IS THIS SAD STORY.
IN 2018 WILMER RODRIGUEZ WAS
BRUTALLY ASSAULTED BY TWO
MEMBERS OF MS-13 AFTER HE
TRIED TO PROTECT TWO BOYS
THEY WERE THREATENING.
RODRIGUEZ AGREED TO TESTIFY
AGAINST HIS ATTACKERS IN
COURT AS GOOD CITIZENS DO.
THAT DECISION COST HIM HIS
LIFE.
ON SUNDAY RODRIGUEZ WAS
BEATEN TO DEATH OUTSIDE HIS
HOME UNTIL RECENTLY,
RODRIGUEZ WOULD HAVE BEEN
PROTECTED BY NEW YORK LAW,
WHICH ALLOWED PROSECUTORS TO
CONCEAL THE NAMES OF
WITNESSES UNTIL SHORTLY
BEFORE TRIAL FOR THEIR
SAFETY.
BUT, A NEW LAW, THIS ONE
PASSED TO HELP CRIMINAL
DEFENDANTS, REQUIRED
PROSECUTORS TO TURN OVER
RODRIGUEZ’ NAME TO THE GANG
MEMBERS’ LAWYERS.
ALMOST IMMEDIATELY GANG
MEMBERS STARTED HARASSING
RODRIGUEZ.
THIS WEEK THEY KILLED HIM.
THAT’S WHAT NEW YORK IS LIKE
NOW.
DO THE RIGHT THING AND YOU
COULD BE MURDERED BY
PREDATORS THE GOVERNMENT IS
DETERMINED TO PROTECT.
LUNANCY?
YES, IT IS LUNANCY.
IT’S NOT CONFINED TO NEW
YORK.
IN 2018 NANCY PELOSI
ATTACKED THE PRESIDENT FOR
DARING TO CALL MS-13 MEMBERS
ANIMALS.
ACCORDING TO PELOSI, TRUMP
WAS MORE IMMORAL THAN THE
GANG MEMBERS HE INSULTED.
>> WE’RE ALL GOD’S CHILDREN.
THERE’S A SPARK OF DIVINITY
IN EVERY PERSON ON EARTH.
AND SO WHEN THE PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES SAYS ABOUT
UNDOCUMENTED IMMIGRANTS
THESE AREN’T PEOPLE, THESE
ARE ANIMALS.
YOU HAVE TO WONDER, DOES HE
NOT BELIEVE IN THE SPARK OF
DIVINITY, THE DIGNITY AND
WORTH OF EVERY PERSON?
EVERY DAY THAT YOU THINK
YOU’VE SEEN IT ALL, ALONG
COMES ANOTHER MANIFESTATION
OF WHY THEIR POLICIES ARE SO
INHUMANE.
>> Tucker: HE IS A SINNER,
MS-13 ARE GOD’S CHILDREN.
WELL, VOXX DID AN ENTIRE
VIDEO HOW MS-13 WERE
MISUNDERSTOOD HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENTS DEEPLY UNDERSTOOD
KIDS ALIGNED BY THE RECENT
MEDIA.
>> WHEN YOU THINK OF THE
GANG MS-13, WHAT DO YOU SEE?
MAYBE SOMETHING LIKE THIS.
OR THIS.
BUT WHAT IF I TOLD YOU THAT
TYPICAL MS-13 GANG MEMBER IN
THE U.S. ACTUALLY LOOKS LIKE
ONE OF THESE YOUNG MEN ON
FACEBOOK?
>> THE MS-13 MEMBERS THAT I
HAVE BEEN FOLLOWING ARE
WORKING AFTER SCHOOL JOBS.
THEY ARE LIVING WITH THEIR
PARENTS.
THEY GET AROUND LONG ISLAND
ON BICYCLES.
>> THERE IS NO INDICATION
THAT WE ARE SEEING A BIGGER
SURGE OF MS-13 THAN WE HAVE
SEEN IN THE PAST.
>> Tucker: VOX WANTS YOU TO
CALM DOWN.
GO BACK TO BED THOSE SCARY
MS-13 GANG MEMBERS JUST A
NIGHTMARE.
EXCEPT THEY WEREN’T.
THEY ARE REAL.
MS-13 IS AN ACTUAL
ORGANIZATION.
IT’S A MASSIVE TRANSNATIONAL
CRIMINAL ORGANIZATION THAT’S
LEFT BEHIND A TRAIL OF
BODIES AND A NUMBER OF
COUNTRIES OVER DECADES.
THREE YEARS AGO WE TRAVELED
TO EL SALVADOR TO SEE WHERE
IT ALL STARTED.
>> WE VISITED A DETENTION
CENTER IN SANDAL HAVE A DOOR
WHERE SUSPECTED MS-13
MEMBERS ARE BEING HELD
BEFORE TRIAL.
MORE THAN 50 MEN PACKED IN A
SINGLE CELL.
THEIR BACKS TO US TO AVOID
BEING IDENTIFIED.
SOME SEEMED BARELY OUT OF
CHILDHOOD THOUGH IN MANY
CASES THEY WERE COVERED IN
GANG TATTOOS, A SIGN OF
THEIR TOTAL COMMITMENT.
BEFORE LONG, SOME OF THESE
GUYS MAY WIND UP IN L.A. OR
LONG ISLAND.
IT’S HAPPENING NOW.
WHAT WAS YOUR ROLE IN THE
GANG.
>> I WAS A [INAUDIBLE]
>> WHAT DOES THAT MEAN.
>> A TRIGGER MAN.
THAT MEANS THAT I -- THAT
MEANS TO KILL.
>> Tucker: HOW OLD WERE YOU
WHEN YOU FIRST KILLED?
>> I WAS 15 YEARS OLD.
THAT WAS MY FIRST HOMICIDE.
>> Tucker: HOW MANY PEOPLE
DID YOU KILL?
>> I KILLED QUITE A FEW.
QUITE A FEW.
>> Tucker: A 15-YEAR-OLD
COMMITTING MURDER.
WE HAVE THOSE IN OUR
COUNTRY, TOO.
IT’S A SAD FACT THAT
SOMETHING WE SHOULD BOTH BE
HORRIFIED AND ASHAMED OF.
CRIME AND VIOLENCE ARE THE
CLEAREST POSSIBLE SIGNS THAT
A SOCIETY ISN’T FUNCTIONING
AS IT SHOULD.
IF THEY INCREASED TO A
CERTAIN POINT, SOCIETIES
DON’T FUNCTION AT ALL AND WE
SHOULD BE WORRIED ABOUT
THAT, ALWAYS.
WE OUGHT TO BE DOING ALL
THAT WE CAN TO BUILD A
PLACE, A COUNTRY WHERE
PEOPLE WHO FOLLOW THE LAW
ARE REWARDED.
THOSE WHO THROUGHOUT IT ARE
PUNISHED AND ABOVE ALL
CHILDREN CAN LIVE IN PEACE
AND SAFETY IT.
USED TO BE OBVIOUS.
IT’S NOT OBVIOUS ANYMORE.
AT THIS MOMENT THERE IS A
BILL PENDING IN THE CONGRESS
CALLED THE NEW WAY FORWARD
ACT.
IT’S RECEIVED ALMOST NO
PUBLICITY AND THAT’S
UNFORTUNATE AS WELL AS
REVEALING.
THE LEGISLATION IS SPONSORED
BY 44 HOUSE DEMOCRATS
INCLUDING ILHAN OMAR AND
ALEXANDRIA OCASIO-CORTEZ.
THERE IS ROUGHLY 4400 WORDS
LONG MEANS IT’S ALMOST
EXACTLY AS LONG AS THE U.S.
CONSTITUTION.
LIKE THE CONSTITUTION, IT’S
DESIGNED TO CREATE A WHOLE
NEW COUNTRY.
THE BILL WOULD ENTIRELY
REMAKE OUR IMMIGRATION
SYSTEM WITH THE EXPLICIT
PURPOSE OF ENSURING THAT
CRIMINALS ARE ABLE TO MOVE
TO THE UNITED STATES AND
SETTLE HERE PERMANENTLY WITH
IMMUNITY.
THEY MAY THINK WE ARE
EXAGGERATING FOR EFFECT.
WE ARE NOT EXAGGERATING NO
EACH A LITTLE BIT.
THE NEW WAY FORWARD MOST
RADICAL PIECE OF LEGISLATION
WE HAVE SEEN IN THIS COUNTRY
EVER.
MAKES THE GREEN NEW DEAL
LOOK LIKE THE STATUS QUO.
THE DOCUMENTS SAYS THIS AND
QUOTING IT VERBATIM.
CONVICTIONS SHOULD NOT LEAD
TO DEPORTATION, END QUOTE.
KEEP IN MIND NOT TALKING
ABOUT CONVICTIONS FOR DOUBLE
PARKING OR EVEN FOR DUI.
THE BILL TARGETS FELONY
CONVICTIONS, SERIOUS CRIMES
THAT COULD SEND TO YOU
PRISON FOR YEARS AND SHOULD.
A PRESS RELEASE FROM
CONGRESSMAN JESUS GARCIA OF
ILLINOIS IS EXPRESSIVE.
IT WILL BREAK THE QUOTE
PRISON TO DEPORTATION
PIPELINE.
SOMETHING MOST OF US ARE
FOR.
HOW DOES THE BILL DO THAT?
UNDER CURRENT U.S. LAW,
LEGAL U.S. IMMIGRANTS CAN BE
DEPORTED IF THEY COMMIT A,
QUOTE, AGGRAVATED FELONY OR
A CRIME OF MORAL TURPITUDE.
THAT IS A VILE DEPRAVED ACT
LIKE MOLESTING CHILDREN.
UNDER THE NEW WAY FORWARD
ACT, CRIMES OF MORAL
TURPITUDE ARE ELIMINATED
ENTIRELY AS A JUSTIFICATION
FOR DEPORTATION.
AND THE CATEGORY OF
AGGRAVATED FELONY GETS
ELIMINATED, TOO.
WHAT DOES THAT MEAN?
CONSIDER THIS?
UNDER CURRENT LAW IMMIGRANTS
WHO COMMIT SERIOUS CRIMES
ROBBERY TO FRAUD TO CHILD
SEXUAL ABUSE MUST BE
DEPORTED REGARDLESS OF THE
SENTENCES THEY RECEIVE.
OTHER CRIMES, LESS SEVERE
ONES LIKE RACKETEERING
REQUIRE DEPORTATION IF THE
PERPETRATOR RECEIVES AT
LEAST A ONE-YEAR SENTENCE.
UNKSD THIS BILL THERE WOULD
NO LONGER BE ANY CRIME THAT
AUTOMATICALLY REQUIRES
DEPORTATION.
NONE.
AND ONE CRIME, FALSIFYING A
PASSPORT, WOULD BE MADE
IMMUNE FROM DEPORTATION NO
MATTER WHAT BECAUSE
APPARENTLY 9/11 NEVER EVEN
HAPPENED AND WE NO LONGER
CARE ABOUT FAKE GOVERNMENT
DOCUMENTS.
BY THE WAY, IF YOU JUST
RENEWED YOUR DRIVER’S
LICENSE TO REAL I.D. ACT YOU
MUST FEEL LIKE AN IMMIGRANT.
BECAUSE IMMIGRANTS ARE
GETTING A PASS.
YOU ARE NOT.
UNDER THE PROPOSED
LEGISLATION FOR CRIMES THAT
WOULD STILL ALLOW
DEPORTATION THE REQUIRED
PRISON SENTENCE WOULD RISE
FROM ONE YEAR TO FIVE YEARS.
WE CHECKED THE BUREAU OF
JUSTICE STATISTICS.
ACCORDING TO FEDERAL DATA
CRIMES LIKE FRAUD THEFT,
WEAPONS OFFENSES ALL CARRY
PRISON SENTENCES OF FEWER
THAN FIVE YEARS.
THAT’S LOOKING AT AVERAGES.
PEOPLE WHO COMMIT RAPE,
CHILD ABUSE EVEN
MANSLAUGHTER AND GET
SENTENCES WITH FEWER THAN
FIVE YEARS.
LOTS OF THEM, ACTUALLY.
IF THE NEW WAY FORWARD ACT
PASSES, IMMIGRANTS WHO
COMMIT THOSE CRIMES AND
RECEIVE THOSE SENTENCES
WOULD REMAIN IN THIS COUNTRY
AND, OF COURSE, THEY WILL BE
ELIGIBLE FOR CITIZENSHIP DAY
ONE, TOO.
OF COURSE.
BUT EVEN THAT IS
UNDERSTATING THE LAW’S
EFFECT.
EVEN A FIVE-YEAR PRISON
SENTENCE WOULDN’T
NECESSARILY BE ENOUGH TO
TRIGGER DEPORTATION.
THE BILL WOULD GRANT
SWEEPING NEW POWERS TO
IMMIGRATION JUDGES ALLOWING
THEM TO NULLIFY A
DEPORTATION ORDER.
THE ONLY REQUIREMENT FOR
THAT IS, QUOTE:  THE
IMMIGRATION JUDGE FINDS SUCH
AN EXERCISE OF DISCRETION
APPROPRIATE AND PURSUANT OF
HUMANITARIAN PURPOSES, TO
ASSURE FAMILY UNITY OR WHEN
IT IS OTHERWISE IN THE
PUBLIC INTEREST.
TALK ABOUT OPEN-ENDED.
IN OTHER WORDS,
ANTI-AMERICAN IMMIGRATION
JUDGES AND THERE ARE A LOT
OF THOSE IN THIS COUNTRY,
WOULD HAVE A BLANK CHECK TO
OPEN THE BORDERS.
YOU WOULD NOT BE VOTING ON
THIS.
IT WOULD HAPPEN ANYWAY.
IS THIS SHOCKING YOU YET?
BECAUSE WE’RE JUST GETTING
STARTED.
WE READ THIS.
PROPOSED
LEGISLATION.
HERE’S ANOTHER POINT.
CURRENT U.S. LAW MAKES DRUG
ADDICTION GROUNDS FOR
DEPORTATION BECAUSE WHY
WOULDN’T IT?
THIS BILL WOULD ELIMINATE
THAT STATUTE.
CURRENT LAW ALSO STATES THAT
THOSE WHO HAVE COMMITTED
DRUG CRIMES ABROAD OR,
QUOTE, ANY CRIMES INVOLVING
MORTAR PRIX TUESDAYINVOLVINGMORE
A MEXICAN DRUG CARTEL LEADER
COULD BE RELEASED FROM
PRISON AND COME TO AMERICA
IMMEDIATELY.
IF HE WANTS HE CAN COME HERE
ILLEGALLY AND STILL WOULDN’T
BE A CRIME BECAUSE AND YOU
ARE WAITING FOR THIS PART
THE BILL ALSO DECRIMINALIZES
ILLEGAL ENTRY INTO AMERICA.
EVEN BY THOSE WE HAVE
PREVIOUSLY DEPORTED.
IN OTHER WORDS, YOU BREAK
OUR LAW, WE SEND YOU OUT.
YOU COME BACK, YOU BREAK IT
AGAIN, CAN YOU STAY.
ACCORDING TO A DOCUMENT
PROMOTING THIS BILL,
CRIMINALIZING ILLEGAL ENTRY
INTO AMERICA IS, QUOTE,
WHITE SUPREMACIST.
THAT’S A QUOTE WHITE
SUPREMACIST.
BY THIS POINT YOU ARE
BEGINNING TO WONDER ARE WE
MAKING THIS UP?
WE ARE NOT MAKING IT UP.
IN FACT, WE ARE BARELY
HALFWAY THROUGH THE BILL.
THE LEGISLATION DOESN’T JUST
MAKE IT HARDER TO DEPORT
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS WHO
COMMIT CRIMES.
DOESN’T MAKE IT JUST EASIER
TO LET CRIMINALS MOVE HERE
ILLEGALLY IT DOES BOTH.
THE BILL WOULD ABOLISH ALL
EXISTING ENFORCEMENT
AGAINST.
THEY WOULD HAVE TO PROVE
THEY ARE DANGEROUS OR A
FLIGHT RISK.
OF COURSE ICE WOULDN’T BE
ABLE TO USE PRIOR BEHAVIORS
PROOF OF DANGER.
THAT’S BANNED.
ICE WOULD HAVE TO OVERCOME
EVEN MORE HURDLES IF A
DETAINEE CLAIMS TO BE GAY OR
TRANSGENDERED IF THEY ARE
UNDER 21 AND CAN’T SPEAK
ENGLISH AND INTERPRETER
ISN’T IMMEDIATELY AVAILABLE
THEY WOULD GET A PASS.
IN OTHER WORDS MUCH EASIER
TO ARREST ILLEGAL ALIEN IN
THIS COUNTRY THAN IT IS TO
ARREST YOU.
THEY’RE THE PROTECTED CLASS
HERE.
YOU ARE JUST SOME LOSER WHO
IS PAYING FOR IT ALL.
BELIEVE IT OR NOT, WE SAVED
THE NUTTEST PART OF THIS
LEGISLATION FOR LAST AND
HERE IS WHAT IT IS.
WHAT COULD BE MORE
DESTRUCTIVE THAN CHANGING
U.S. LAW SPECIFICALLY TO
ALLOW RAPIST, CHILD
MOLESTERS AND DRUG DEALERS
TO STAY IN AMERICA?
HOW ABOUT THIS?
USING TAXPAYER MONEY TO
BRING DEPORTED CRIMINALS
BACK INTO AMERICA.
THAT’S RIGHT.
THIS BILL WOULD NOT ABOLISH
YOUR RIGHT TO CONTROL WHO
LIVES IN YOUR COUNTRY, BUT
IT INEVENTS A BRAND NEW
RIGHT, QUOTE, THE RIGHT TO
COME HOME.
IT ORDERS THE GOVERNMENT TO
CREATE A QUOTE PATHWAY TO
THOSE PREVIOUSLY DEPORTED TO
APPLY RETURN TO THEIR HOMES
AND FAMILIES IN THE UNITED
STATES AS LONG AS THEY WOULD
HAVE BEEN ELIGIBLE TO STAY
UNDER THE NEW LAW.
IT’S RETROACTIVE, IN OTHER
WORDS.
DHS MUST SPEND TAXPAYER
DOLLARS TRANSPORTING
CONVICTED CRIMINAL ILLEGAL
ALIENS BACK INTO THE UNITED
STATES.
NOT MAKING THIS UP.
SO WHO WOULD BE ELIGIBLE FOR
THESE FLIGHTS?
TENS OF THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE
WE KICKED OUT OF THIS
COUNTRY FOR ALL KINDS OF
CRIMES, SEXUAL ABUSE,
ROBBERY, ASSAULT, DRUG
TRAFFICKING, WEAPONS
TRAFFICKING, HUMAN
TRAFFICKING.
FROM 2002 TO 2018, 480,000
PEOPLE DEPORTED FOR ILLEGAL
ENTRY OR REENTRY INTO
AMERICA.
UNDER THIS BILL YOU WOULD
HAVE TO BUY EACH OF THEM A
PLANE TICKET TO COME HOME.
THOSE TICKETS ALONE WOULD
COST ABOUT A BILLION
DOLLARS.
AND THAT’S BEFORE DEMOCRATS
MAKE YOU START PAYING FOR
THESE CRIMINALS’ FREE
HEALTHCARE, TOO, WHICH THEY
PLAN TO DO AND HAVE SAID SO.
THE NEW WAY FORWARD ACT
FUNDAMENTALLY INVESTORS
EVERY ASSUMPTION YOU HAVE
ABOUT THIS COUNTRY.
UNDER THIS LEGISLATION THE
CRIMINALS ARE THOUGHT
VICTIMS.
LAW ENFORCEMENT IS
ILLEGITIMATE.
IT’S RACIST.
JUST LIKE THE COUNTRY YOU
LIVE.
IN JUST LIKE YOU ARE.
AND THE ONLY SOLUTION IS TO
GET RID OF BOTH.
AMERICA WOULD BE BETTER OFF
WITH A BORDERLESS REST STOP
FOR THE WORLD’S PREDATORS
AND PARASITES.
THAT’S THE POINT OF THIS.
AND WE’RE NOT OVERSTATING.
GO READ IT.
THIS IS A BIG DEAL.
THIS IS NOT A SMALL -- THIS
IS NOT RENAMING A POST
OFFICE.
IT’S HARD TO BELIEVE ANY
AMERICAN WOULD PUT THESE
IDEAS ON PAPER, MUCH LESS
TRY TO PASS THEM INTO LAW.
AND, YET, REMARKABLY THAT’S
HAPPENING AND EVEN MORE
REMARKABLY THE PRESS HAS
IGNORED IT.
THIS ISN’T HAPPENING IN
SECRETS IT’S HAPPENING IN
THE HOUSE OF
REPRESENTATIVES.
SCORES OF DEMOCRATS HAVE
BACKED THIS BILL.
BUT THE LEGISLATION HAS NOT
BEEN MENTIONED IN THE "NEW
YORK TIMES."
HASN’T BEEN MENTIONED ON
CNN, A NEWS CHANNEL.
OR EVEN IN SELF-DESCRIBED
CONSERVATIVE OUTLETS LIKE
NATIONAL REVIEW.
NO MENTION.
CONSIDER IF THIS WERE
WORKING THE OTHER WAY?
IF A LONE, I DON’T KNOW,
REPUBLICAN STATE LEDGES LAY LEGI
HAD PROPOSED A BILL THIS
EXTREME WE MAKE THE BILL
COMPLETELY THE PRESIDENT
HIMSELF WOULD BE EXPECTED TO
ANSWER FOR IT.
CNN WOULD DEMAND THAT HE
DISAVOW IT EVEN IF HE HAD
NEVER HEARD OF IT BEFORE.
WHEN ONE FIFTH OF THE ENTIRE
DEMOCRATIC CAUCUS BACK AS
BILL DEMANDING THAT YOU
IMPORT ILLEGAL ALIEN FELONS
AND THEN PAY FOR IT, IT’S A
NONEVENT IN THE AMERICAN
MEDIA.
THEY DON’T THINK YOU SHOULD
KNOW ABOUT IT.
AND THAT’S DANGEROUS.
IF WE’RE BEING HONEST.
WHETHER THE PRESS CARES OR
NOT, THESE ARE THE STAKES OF
THE 2020 ELECTION.
AND YOU HAVE A RIGHT TO KNOW
WHAT THEY ARE.
A GROWING WING OF THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY VIEWS
AMERICA ITSELF AS
ESSENTIALLY ILLEGITIMATE.
A ROGUE STATE IN WHICH
EVERYTHING MUST BE DESTROYED
AND REMADE.
OUR LAWS, OUR INSTITUTIONS,
OUR CUSTOMS, OUR HISTORY,
OUR VALUES AND, OF COURSE,
THAT’S THE POINT OF ALL OF
THIS AN ENTIRELY NEW COUNTRY
IN WHICH RESISTANCE IS